hello in this video we'll talk about
immunofluorescence and its clinical
application immunofluorescence is a
technique that is widely used in
biomedical research and in
clinical settings for disease diagnosis
today's focus would be
how immunofluorescence can be used in
clinical settings for several disease
diagnosis in this video we'll look at
the principle of immunofluorescence the
direct and indirect immunofluorescence
assay step by step i would walk you
through the procedure and we would try
to understand how this procedure can be
used for disease detection so stay tuned
till the end of this video
immunofluorescence is based on antigen
antibody interaction
antigen binds with antibody with several
non-covalent interactions like hydrogen
bond ionic bond hydrophobic interaction
etc
let me tell you that there are two
variants of these immunofluorescence
direct immunofluorescence and indirect
immunofluorescence in direct
immunofluorescence
a usage of single antibody is preferred
which detects the target
now in indirect
immunofluorescence two antibodies are
used
one unconjugated primary antibody and a
conjugated secondary antibody very often
the unconjugated antibody comes from
patient samples
now let's move to a laboratory setting
to understand how immunofluorescence is
performed
first tip of the immunofluorescence is
to fix the sample using four person
paraformality height
then permeabilization is done in
presence of some kind of detergent like
triton x 100 which permeabilize the
membrane and ensures the antibody can
get inside the cell and detect the
antigens
now the next step is antigen retrieval
which is optional but antigen retrieval
is crucial because many of the time
the
epitopes are hidden inside the native
structure of the protein that's why
antibody cannot recognize the epitopes
so these epitopes need to be revealed by
changing of temperature and ph such that
the antibody can easily detect the
epitope
and that is why antigen retrieval is
performed
many are cases
now next step is to perform blocking
blocking is often done with horse or
lamp serum
and the key goal of blocking
is to reduce the chances of non-specific
binding and it would promote the
specific binding
ultimately primary antibody incubation
is performed
and in this step
antibodies are added on the slide
generally using a liquid blocker
particular mark is
drawn and the antibodies are added
this step is performed overnight in
general
and at this point of time the primary
antibodies should be binding to the
antigen
the primary antibody can come from
patient sample in clinical setting or in
biomedical research scientists create
monoclonal antibodies against specific
protein of interest if you want to know
how monoclonal antibodies are generated
using hybridoma technology you can click
on the i button
after primary antibody incubation
unbound antibodies are removed by
washing these several times next
secondary
antibody incubation is performed
and in this step fluorophore conjugated
secondary antibodies are added these
fluorophore conjugated antibodies detect
the fc region of the primary antibody
since these fluorophores are light
sensitive it is
preferred in a dark setting
now
we need to understand that
fluorescence based detection is only one
type of detection where fluorophore
conjugated antibodies are used there
could be calorimetric detection as well
where enzyme linked antibodies are used
and in clinical settings conjugated
antibodies are really useful anyway
after secondary antibody incubation
washing should be done to remove all the
unnecessary signals or tissue debris etc
ultimately
the slides are mounted with copper and
they are ready to detect under a
fluorescence microscope let us take some
example of direct and indirect
immunofluorescence in terms of clinical
setting
pemphigus vulgaris is an autoimmune
disease where blistering of the skin or
the mucosal membrane takes place
and
these particular disease can be
diagnosed with the help of
direct immunofluorescence
so a periled tissue is taken on a slide
and it can be demonstrated that this
particular
tissue
is positive for igg or igm and these
antibodies are deposited on the
intercellular spaces
that is why
there would be
honeycomb mails like pattern
another example
for
indirect immunofluorescence
come from
the detection of systemic lupus
erythematosus using antinuclear antigen
test or anatist
where the patient sample is collected
and the antibodies are
incubated with heptu cell lines f2 cell
lines are
important because it is a array of
nuclear antigens
so there could be two scenario one
patient's blood sample has antinuclear
antibodies present
and antinuclear antibodies could be
absent in the patient sample so if the
antinuclear antibodies are present in
the patient sample
then we would get immunofluorescence
otherwise we won't get an
immunofluorescence
looking at the immunofluorescence
pattern a doctor can understand whether
it is
positive or not and there are several
characteristic pattern
on which
several interpretations can be taken and
in this video we are not going to
talk about this particular aspect in
details but using immunofluorescence
this particular disease can be diagnosed
now just like we have seen for systemic
lupus these are the immunofluorescence
pattern for
bolus pemphigoid and pemphigus vulgaris
so in short we understood that
immunofluorescence pattern can aid in
disease diagnosis
so in summary i would like to say we
talked about the principle of
immunofluorescence direct and indirect
immunofluorescence clinical and
biomedical applications of
immunofluorescence so if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can support my channel in patreon you
can also support me via vim upi app
indian viewers can support me via that
your support means a lot to me you can
take my courses in an academy using my
code ap 10 can give you 10 discount
thank you
you